Sometimes there was a man,
he's the man for his time and place.
He fits right in there and that's the
dude in Los Angeles and even if he's a
lazy man and the dude was most certainly
that quite possibly the Las Vegas and
Los Angeles County which would place him
high and are running for laziest
worldwide,
but sometimes there's a man,
sometimes there's a man.
I think many would agree when I say that
the big Lebowski can easily be seen as
one of the greatest cult classics off
our time to film that as inspire
thousands of Halloween costumes,
so called Lebowski fest and even a
religion must have received poorly upon
its original release in 1998.
The film was described by critics as
fitbit and spacious.
It was only in the early two thousands
that the film started to get into mess
following and appreciation that made it
the classic that it is today.
It such a steady increasing in
popularity is really intriguing.
Scholars,
Paul Martin and fellow renegot argued
that is jus to a period of economic and
social prosperity in America when the
big Lebowski was released according to
them chew to this,
many Americans weren't as perceptive to
the social critiques that the big
Lebowski could offer.
This changed however,
during the two thousands with impactful
events or 9:11,
the bloody and problematic war in Iraq
and eventually the economic crash of
2008.
Then the social and political critique
of the Big Lebowski Fountain audience
and important critique that can be found
in the big Lebowski starts in the
opening scene.
The narrative makes a point of stating
the film takes place during the 1991
Gulf War and that the dudes is just the
man for his time.
The golf course was a time in American
politics where aggression most used as a
means of conflict resolution.
This will not stand.
This will not stand this aggression
against a Kuwait
aggression as a means of conflict.
Resolution is a major theme in the movie
everywhere around two dudes,
all the characters to violence and
intimidation to resolve conflicts or
pursue their own interests.
Fucking fascist
Lebowski,
only the dude because he is of course a
pacifist.
These guys,
you know,
good like me.
There was a conscientious objector.
It is not a coincidence that the other
Lebowski,
the millionaire who was quite willing to
use aggression and clearly is the
personification of American capitalism.
Remarkably looks like the then Secretary
of Defense,
Dick Cheney,
however it is the dude's friend,
Walter,
who embodies this American policy of
aggression during the Gulf War.
I'm talking about drawing a line in the
sand.
Dude,
across this line,
you do not.
Melissa is constantly set off and users
aggression and intimidation to achieve
his goals.
Just the whole world.
God crazy.
Am I the only one around here?
Just like Jen about the Ra market zero.
They're calling the cops man.
Put the zero
piece of Walter fucking around Taro.
He refers to the goal for when he
criticizes to dude for being a pacifist.
You know that's your answer for
everything and we'll be putting out
something.
Pacifism is not looking at our current
situation with that camel.
Fuck her in a wreck.
Pacifism is not something to hide
behind.
Just take it easy,
man.
I'm perfectly calm.
Do you could even argue that what he is
yelling in this hilarious scene refers
to Iraq treatment of Kuwait and
Americans reaction to this.
Let's see what happens when he fucking
stranger
Larry Flurry,
flurry.
When you fuck a stranger in the act,
the film is clearly critical of this
means of conflict resolution and this of
the American politics of starting the
Gulf war against Iraq because throughout
the film,
and especially with regards to Walter
Section,
the violence only leads to further
problems,
destruction of their own property,
and even a death.
God,
they shot him.
There
weren't any shots fired.
It's a heart attack
myself,
but I'm pumping blood.
My pants
well kind of course.
Imagine how such a political critique of
American politics of progressions as a
means of conflict resolutions against
Iraq gained popularity in the formations
early two thousands when the highly
criticized second Iraq war started as
Martin and Renner Gar state to both
subtle and explicit commentary.
The Big Lebowski challenges the values
and the dominant national policies of 99
slash one America and celebrates the
qualities of the Common Pacific cystic
citizen.
Yet besides the political critique in
the big Lebowski,
we can also find a broader critique or
society as a whole.
I think that that is from this critique
that we can explain the cultural impact
of the big Lebowski,
the Lebowski fest,
and the religion of Judaism,
which basically preaches going with the
flow and taking it easy.
Martin and renegot explained this to
what they call the carnivalesque
qualities of the big Lebowski.
The carnivalesque can be explained in
different ways,
yet it comes down to a way of humor that
seeks to deconstruct and ridicule social
norms,
hierarchies,
and power,
six,
to exposed to artificial construction or
society and makes fun of it.
Now,
the two most important qualities that
marked a kind arco desk realism and
reversal of hierarchies.
Fucking grotesque realism means taking
down and ridiculing everything that is
considered proper aunts.
Respectable.
It is lowering everything that is
considered holy back to the three of
earth and body.
Examples of imagery that are a grotesque
realism are images of bodily functions,
old and fat bodies,
sex,
pregnancy,
and preventing it.
Let me tell you something or you pull
any crazy shit with us.
You flash a piece out on the lanes they
got away from you and stick it up your
ass and pulled the fucking trigger.
Delayed goes,
Jesus.
You said in mind,
nobody fucks with Jesus
in the big Lebowski.
This starts,
for example,
with the peeing on the rock and the car
that smells like urine,
but it is also seen in a buddy's of the
characters in the big Lebowski.
We don't see beautiful movie star
buddies.
Instead,
the camera focuses on overweight middle
age guys with beer bellies and food
stains on my shirt.
It is to this humoristic focus on the
lower above lead that the audience is
asked to look differently at it.
Fucking interesting,
man.
That's fucking interesting.
Grotesque realism can be seen and
profanity and overtly sexual dialogue as
well.
This is used as a way to break through
social hierarchies.
We can see this,
for example,
in math,
who is very aware of how use of language
can break through social convention and
create social power.
My art has been commended as being
strongly vaginal,
which bothers some men.
The word itself makes someone
uncomfortable,
but Jina oh yeah.
Yes.
I don't like hearing it and find it
difficult to say,
whereas without batting an eye man refer
to his dick or his rod or his Johnson
Johnson,
funnily enough,
however,
since the dude is also very unconcerned
with social convention and
respectability,
he is rather and faced a better example,
therefore will be bunny.
She first becomes characterized as a
trophy wife or for rich old millionaire.
A woman in her position is often
expected to serve as elegant ICANDY and
it has a lack of social power,
yet too overtly sexual dialogue.
She breaks to this convention,
the social construction of what is
considered respectable behavior and
gains in a way social power.
Second Wonderful Woman
Rah,
very fond of are very free spirited
brand.
Can't watch that.
That's marvelous.
This brings me to the second and most
important feature of the carnivalesque,
the inversion of social hierarchies.
This breaks down hierarchies in society,
but I did the training of rulers and let
alone take their places.
This way,
the audience has shown the artificial
nature of these hierarchies and
encouraged to rethink such a system.
We already see this in a dude as the
protagonist.
Instead of the typical American
handsome,
capable of leading men hero,
we get a bathrobe and flip flops wearing
bore bomb who stole to be possibly the
laziest man in the world.
The man for his time and place.
Yeah.
Just like your opinion,
man.
Yeah.
It's the other Lebowski who is referred
to by the dude as the big Lebowski,
a successful millionaire at the top of
the social ladder who gained his wealth
by supposedly a life part work turns out
to be a total failure in business who
lives off an allowance from the trust of
his deceased spouse and to refer back to
the relevance of the Gulf War and the
dudes dream,
the supposedly fearful,
powerful dictator.
Saddam Hussein is working as a bowling
shoe attendant offering.
The dude that unique pair of silver and
gold bowling shoes is reinforces to do
kidney position and show Saddam Hussein
and the lowly status that's modern and
renegade states,
so such inverted rows.
The audiences enabled to see social
reality as a construct under this
encouraged to question it in the end.
This is one of the key concepts of the
film.
It puts us viewers to be aware of the
constructed nature of society and shows
us we are not obliged to take part in
it.
The dude is living a lifestyle
completely in opposition to Alice,
respectfully seen as the American dream.
Yet he is content living by its own
ethics and sense of purpose as he says.
Yeah.
Well,
the dude abides to construction nature
of society who doesn't conform to it.
Instead,
he's out there taking it easy for us all
and invite us to do the same
band song in Turkey or b days.
All right.
Thanks so much for watching everyone.
So it took a while to make this video.
Uh,
I was very busy with my law specialist
subjects in the beginning of [inaudible]
17.
We hope to start producing more videos
more often.
There will be another video for it in
the middle of December.
A good friend of us,
one for patrons wanted to remain chair
that to never forget king's Day,
2015.
Uh,
if any of you want to help us make more
videos and get access to more content,
you can support some patrial,
a short additional.
We're an essay about this video will be
posted in the next couple of days.
For the rest of you,
we will see you the next video.